this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
[Music]
what's up wisecrack greg here ready to
have a most
resplendent time talking about a film
with the best dialogue
in the history of cinema who's he he's
billy the kid
[Music]
he's famous dude let's back him
bill and ted's excellent adventure is
frequently dismissed as a silly team
flick
about two stoners metalheads who would
literally
rather do anything than go to school but
what if it's secretly a genius film
about the radical power of learning
no way no way
well maybe wait dude maybe way dude
let's find out if bill and ted's
excellent adventure is deep
or dumb we swear it will be
[Music]
non-heinous or maybe the opposite anyway
spoilers and a most triumphant time
ahead
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor
surfsharkvpn a vpn is a virtual private
network
that encrypts your web traffic so you
can protect your passwords
photos and private messages online
surfshark is simple and easy to use
and it doesn't slow down your internet
speed unlike some other vpns
you can also use it on any device so
you're protected no matter where you go
surf shark isn't just a vpn it also
offers additional features like
clean web which blocks ads and malware
that may pop up while browsing
their other feature blind search
protects your browser from serving you
targeted ads
or sponsored sites if you use the link
in the description right now
you can get surf shark vpn for 85 off
its normal price
plus three extra months for free go to
surfshark
dot deal slash wisecrack or click the
link in the description
protect yourself online and download
surfsharkvpn today
now back to the show now a quick recap
bill and ted centers on two pleasant
metal heads remarkable only in the fact
that they are the future saviors of the
world
except right now they're about to flunk
history which will get young keanu reeve
sent to military school
you failed history you flunk out of
school
you know what that would mean don't you
ted
that i would have to go to oates
military academy
and destroy the duo sick band
their only means of salvation give a
killer oil report
on an apparently random assortment of
historical time periods
just when our hope seems lost and keanu
might have to open a book
a guy named rufus from the future shows
up with a dope time traveling phone
booth
they use it to kidnap historical figures
bring them to the present
and ace the [ __ ] out of that
presentation as a result
our dudes are on track to save the world
so long as they can learn to play their
instruments first
the end so could this time traveling
stone affair possibly
be deeper than the sofa eyes of one mr
reeves
we got two arguments to throw at you
here's number one
bill and ted might be all about the
failures of western style education
it's no secret that these dudes do not
care about their own learning
we're late for what school dude
the classroom is presented as a place
where facts are to be memorized and
regurgitated
not only is this a very boring way to
learn it's also a really big societal
problem
according to educator and philosopher
paolo frary
and his banking concept of education
frary argued that the western education
functions under the premise
that the teacher knows everything
important and the student functionally
knows nothing education is therefore
something to be given from the teacher
to the student deposited like coins into
your dumb old piggy bank of a brain
according to frary the result is that
the scope of action allowed to the
students extends only as far as
receiving
fouling and storing the deposits this
is visible right away in bill and ted's
where we see the chalkboard of a social
studies classroom filled with a short
list
of historical time periods waiting to be
systematically deposited
into these impressionable minds bill and
ted's teacher doesn't ask them
to argue about the possible causes of
world war one
or theorize if powdered wigs were good
for head banging
he asked them to recite admittedly very
simple facts
who was joan of arc
noah's wife frary who spent his life
educating impoverished disenfranchised
folks in brazil
believe the banking model to be
inherently oppressive
treating students like adaptable
manageable beings
you fill someone's brain with random
facts and make sure that they don't have
the will
or ability to think critically about
those facts
and from there you don't have to worry
about anyone changing the world
whether through a mass protest movement
or
weirdly influential metal ban if this is
a problem with normal school
it's certainly dialed up to 11 in
military school
an institution built to teach kids to
shut up
and listen to authority and fittingly
it's the prospect of ted leaving wild
stallions
to become a cadet mindlessly doing
burpees that threatens the very rad
utopia
that all boy rufus was sent to protect
but how do you overcome the drone-minded
nature of education banking
according to frary you do so by becoming
an active participant in your learning
specifically frary believed in the power
of problem posing
education in which the teacher enters a
dialogue with the students
rendering all participants jointly
responsible for a process in which all
grow
kind of like a teacher who encourages
you to argue with them about george
washington's
farewell address instead of quizzing you
about what year he crossed the delaware
and problem posing seems at least a bit
similar to what's happening between
rufus and bill and ted
they're not too dumb dumbs for him to
fill with information
he approaches them with reverence and
respect although
admittedly my guy is in a real weird
spot
because he both has to help them and
worship them as saviors
of the world rufus shows them the time
machine teaches them how to use it
that book will give you the number of
any place you want to go
and explains its implications these are
the circuits of history gentlemen
he even gives a little historical
background austria
1805 the french have just invaded but
then he leaves them to their own devices
gentlemen you're on your own bill and
ted now must pursue
a more active educational model
essentially
rounding up a crew of historical figures
to become their substitute teachers
along the way they creatively solve
various issues they encounter
ranging from broken antennas to figuring
out how to get in touch with the
medieval babes of their dreams
how are we gonna meet him key to the
problem-posing educational style
frary said is communication as he put it
authentic thinking thinking that is
concerned about reality
does not take place in ivory tower
isolation but only in communication
by communication we can only hope that
frary was imagining this glorious
exchange
our boys have over socrates writing just
before meeting him
the only true wisdom consists in knowing
that you know
nothing
that's us dude what's more bill and ted
immediately enter a dialogue with
socrates
aura show crates sharing their own
wisdom gleaned from growing up in the
80s
all we are is dust in the wind dude
dust
wind dude which appropriately
blows this athenian's mind over the
course of their journey instead of
simply memorizing joan of arc's name
they'll learn about her youthful
achievements instead of memorizing
sigmund freud's theory of the oedipus
complex
ted undergoes analysis by the good
doctor
perhaps most importantly bill and ted
are empowered with the knowledge
that they have a tremendous effect over
history they are our saviors
after all this notion of a student's
active role in the making of history
couldn't possibly be more antithetical
to the feeling you get
when memorizing facts about alexander
the great
as fairy put it problem posing education
trains
students in the art of how to see the
world not as a static reality
but as a reality and process and
transformation
while frary was talking about empowering
people
to think they could change the present
or their own circumstances
this film literalizes that idea by
making bill and ted
actually capable of changing the future
as they learn how to control the forces
around them
and harness that power to help them
achieve their goals
you can almost see what fairy calls the
emergence
of consciousness and critical
intervention in reality
after the report will time travel back
to two days ago steal your dad's keys
and leave them here
in a weird and perhaps slightly
metaphorical way bill and ted are taking
charge of their own education and along
the way
discovering their own agency and even
learning some things
he is sometimes known as the father of
modern thought
he was the teacher of plato who was in
turn the teacher of aristotle
and like ozzy osbourne that's repeatedly
accused of corruption
of the young now when i first heard this
idea i thought oh
hell no come on this movie is dumb as
hell
and maybe it's a stretch to compare
stoner bros
to kids rising up against the government
in south america but i gotta say
i'm pretty convinced on this one so
convinced i'm gonna rate this argument
pretty damn
deep but now we gotta get to the real
wild stuff argument number two
here's the pitch not only is this movie
about the failures of our education
system
but it's also an exploration of the
shortcomings of the written word itself
damn i feel attic all right to get to
the bottom of this
we need to look at the dichotomy between
an oral versus a literary society
i.e one dominated by what comes out of
your mouth hole
or is received by our ear holes versus
one dominated by what you read via your
eye holes
and right bill and ted begins in the
modern world
where the written word reigns supreme
we're a literary society through and
through
but they are punished for their refusal
to you know
read and learn fixed facts about history
correctly
thus leading them to imminent academic
failure
however bill and ted are the absolute
embodiment of a burgeoning
oral culture giving their tendency to
communicate via song and music
even when discoursing with futuristic
weirdos
according to scholar lynn lundqvist the
way history functions in an oral versus
literary society
is critical to understanding bill
instead in a literary society
landquist explains historical narratives
are fixed
rigid and unchangeable after all you
can't change the printed word
in a normal society where storytellers
can adapt each story a song
to suit their audiences myths reigns
supreme like how homer's odyssey is
likely a combination of several
different enduring stories told from
generation to generation in ancient
greece
that eventually got written down what's
more
oral societies tend to be more equal
because as lundqvist explains
the written word was historically
weaponized by the powerful
to deny rights to the illiterate masses
in contrast
all traditions like folk songs or
folklore
are accessible to just about everyone
maybe it's a weird coincidence but just
about every literary society we visit in
bill and ted
is violent and cruel while all bay
societies like athens
are presented as peaceful and idyllic it
was most tranquil
and also fittingly they kidnapped
socrates
who was one of the last philosophers of
ancient greece
that we know of to communicate solely
through oral tradition
he also famously feared that reading and
writing would cause the downfall of
civilization
the only reason we think we know what
kind of stuff socrates said
is because his student plato wrote a
bunch of it down in keeping with this
bill and ted seemed to epitomize the
egalitarian nature
of an oral society when cramming for
their tests
they solicit the conversational
anecdotal help
of various patrons of the circle k in
keeping with classic
oral learning the leading that car over
there said that marco polo was in the
year
1275. and critically their teacher
perhaps sensing their resistance to
literary culture
throws our boys a bone and offers them
the chance to pass
via a dope oral presentation
frary might extra appreciate the fact
that this presentation
is structured around the idea of
communication
and critical thinking bill and ted must
explain what various historical figures
might think
and say about their present day world we
love san dimas
which brings us to the other primary
tension myth versus history
whereas the history they learn in school
is fixed and rigid
made up of dates and hard to memorize
facts bill and ted's a historical
mission to bring figures of the past
into the present
is the very stuff of myth making by
collecting joan of arc napoleon and crew
bill and ted are tearing apart the
history that our literary society is so
obsessed with
sure they absorb actual facts along
their interactive history lesson
[Music]
nah just got a minor edible complex but
they also used this new knowledge
to draw a historical comparisons a time
when much of the world looked like the
cover of the led zeppelin album houses
of the holy
they even called socrates the ozzy
osbourne of athens
underscoring what lundqvist calls the
collapse of historical context
taking place in favor of a more mythical
style
less concerned with literal truth what's
more as
long quest explains bill and ted's myth
telling
unlike rigid history can be customized
to fit their audience of san dimas high
schoolers
nowhere more fittingly than in this
moment
excellent to each other
and party on
dudes the evidence of bill and ted as
champions of an oral society
is telegraphed when we see the future a
place that has been changed by the power
of bill and ted's music
where the words they have said in the
past have been carried down across
generations
now i'm not entirely convinced but
lundqvist has more
she argues that the film sequel bill and
ted's bogus journey
further champions oral society bill and
ted have apparently established a
university
where students learn orally via
headphones
and through interactive lessons with
historical figures what's more
the movies villain who wants to change
history and dethrone bill and ted
as the world's saviors outlines his
diabolical plan
in a book a book that he makes people
read and calls
the new history once again literary
society is clearly the enemy of our
favorite metalhead duo
now it pains me a little bit to imagine
a society where
literature doesn't matter but i gotta
give it to monkeys man
the all versus written society bit is a
little convincing
i'm not saying that bill and ted is
intentionally saying all this
however we do think that the series may
be
inadvertently makes a most excellent
argument about the power of
active empowered learning in primarily
all societies
at the same time it majorly champions
the power of myths
and helping us better understand the
world and our place in it whether we're
the saviors of humanity or not
and so in our final moments is bill and
ted deep
or is it as dumb as an infinite loop of
keanu reeves saying
i'm going to outrage your 10th grade
american history teacher and rate this
take on this film
surprisingly incredibly deep but what do
you guys think has wild stallions rotted
our brains
or is there really a lot more going on
in this film that first meets the eye
let us know in the comments as always
huge thanks to our patrons for all your
support
slam that subscribe button like it's a
portal to the future
and as always thanks for watching peace
[Applause]
[Music]